tell you a crazy story you ever hear
John Skipper yes John Skipper ran ESPN
hates USA hates it this is a fact and
this is this is a true story ESPN's at
the top of their game you know these
guys are killing it in Revenue John
Skipper's never ever gonna take the USA
so we're we're in a real tough Place
John Skipper's cocaine dealer is gonna
rat him out what what
wait wait so he has to tell Disney my
cocaine dealer is probably gonna go
public whatever so he has to step down
from ESPN right at the time that we're
trying to make a TV deal
who do they put in as the new president
Jimmy pataro and he loves the UFC he
loves the USA we end up doing the ESPN
deal